You'd expect a 600-year-old sport to have played through its identity crisis, not the case
for pool. The sport's very name comes from pooling money to determine odds, and wadring
lens pool mystique. Hustling and pool go together like acoustic and chalk, but that's as much
a curse as a blessing. How can a sport thrive at the highest level when so much of it exists
in the shadows? Well, here comes Shane Van Boning from Rapid City. As we first told you
in December, at age 39 with no interest in gambling, Van Boning is arguably the best American
player ever to break a rack, and was ranked number one in the world for 2022. He also happens
to be deaf. Can the South Dakota kid help turn pool popular in bars and basements, but
not on TV into a proper pro sport? We hit the circuit with him to find out.
The story will continue in a moment.
Another day, another casino hotel, Shane Van Boning spends 300 days a year on the road playing
professional pool. Today he's clocking in early at the jamboree of American pool tournaments,
the Derby City Classic.
Held every January outside Louisville, Derby City is a colorful expression of pool split
personality. Downstairs a felt ocean drawing dozens of the world's best practitioners. They
compete 12 hours a day for nine days in multiple events. This winner is smiling ear to ear
and his check tops out at $16,000. But upstairs it's a different economy. Behold pool's zestier
side. Pop up action room standing room only where pros, amateurs and wannabes alike come
to the table for unofficial competition. The signs say no smoking and no gambling, and
we short in see any smoking. Ten sometimes hundreds of thousands of dollars, big timber they
call it, change hands until the sun comes up. One player we didn't see gambling upstairs,
Shane Van Boning. A generational talent known for his killer break.
Van Boning has won the US Open five times in been named player of the decade. Depth since
birth he wears hearing aids and shuts down any question this makes it harder for him to
play pool. It's actually a big advantage for me. How's that? You know when I play a full
tournament I can just shut it off. Do you shut your hearing aids off on the play? When
I won my first US Open, I had everything off I would focus total siles. Yes. I'm totally
like 100% zone in. Never more zoned in than in 2018 when he led the United States to
victory over Europe at the Moscone Cup. Pools answer to golf's rider cup. And he is going
for it. He closed it out with an off angle long distance one nine combo. This high risk
high reward pressure packed shot. What a shot. Shane Van Boning and team USA. Unbelievable
finish. Think you could have made that shot. We went to Rapid City, South Dakota, a side pocket
of America to Van Boning's pool hall where he explained that making balls disappear into
pockets is only half of pool excellence. It's also about setting up your next shots.
Cueball control they call it. And I'm going to make the cue ball stop right here so I can shoot
the two inside. Then I'm going to say, well, you did that. How? How did you do that?
Just hit it right below center. So now it lines up that next ball perfectly. Yeah. I'm so
struck by the geometry of all this. Yeah, I love geometry. He's all about the angles.
Van Boning says he can see every angle on the table. A six sense that comes from practicing
as much as 10 hours a day, shooting half a million balls a year. I want to make the shot
perfect. You know, the only way to hit a perfect you got to do it over and over and over.
Can you be perfect in the sport? No. I try to show how it's done all these years.
Van Boning comes by it honestly. His grandfather Gary Bloomberg, a known trick shot artist,
opened pool halls off by 90. Easy access for hustlers passing across the great plains. But
these rooms were family friendly places. So much so Shane got his first pool cue when he was two
and went to the pool room every day after school. Not just to play but to escape kids who picked on him
for being deaf. How bad did it get? The kid was start throwing rocks at me. They would put gum in
my hair and then I would go home to my mom and I'd be going home crying, you know, and then
she made me feel better by asking me, you want to go to the pool? Why did coming to the pool room
make you feel better? You know when you're walking to the pool and what do you see? You know, you see
people having a good time. But it was more than that. He had prodigious ability for thinking multiple
strokes ahead. When Van Boning was 18, he hit the road. He and his uncle loaded into an RV looking
for money games. Came to play pools, bats. Of course they did. The hustler, that stealth road man,
armed only with a wooden stick and confidence, divorcing the locals from their cash,
had been romanticized for decades, not least by Paul Newman. This reporter was so taken by pool
hustling he once wrote a book about it. For Van Boning, the romance hit the rocks abruptly.
I actually was playing the pool in Tennessee and I was playing this guy for money and we were
playing for a whole lot and he was losing and he picked up the keyboard and threw it at me.
Where'd he hit you? Hit me right on the chest. It's the kind of thing you do to start a fight.
Yeah. How'd you react? I told my uncle I said, I don't want to do this anymore. I don't want to live
on a road anymore. It's just too dangerous. Here we go for the title. He chose to go legit and
began playing in winning proper tournaments, though less lucrative than the rambling gambling life
Van Boning enjoyed being a professional. Did you worry that coming in off the road was going to
impact your finances? I know some of the pool players like the top pool players were making money
so if they can do it, I can do it. But pool is a deceptively tricky sport. Next up to superpowers
Just ask Shane Scottish counterpark Jason Shaw, another top player. Earlier this year,
Shaw holed up in a Virginia pool room for five days and broke the straight pool record
making 714 shots in a row. The stuff that happens in pool will completely screw your brain up.
What do you mean? You'll see shots and you'll be like, how did that happen? You'll hear that
all day. How did that land over there? Did you see that? How did that went in? In pool, you see
every game something weird will happen. Does that make it more exhilarating or more frustrating?
Both mentally you want to flip the table at some point. You ever flip the table? No, I've fought
about it a few times. People come in and say, how hard could it be? It's just a rectangle with
six packets. Yeah, and then 20 minutes later there's still 15 balls on the table. They're not
pausing the ball and the guys like stretching their head like, thought this was easy. It's not.
We watched you at Derby City play Jason Shaw. Jason Hoop? Yeah.
The arrival? Yeah, it's been going on for several years now. He's a great player and
well you're going to have a battle. You okay with that? Yeah, you have to step losing.
If you don't want to step losing you're going to go crazy. I'll stick his aside right here.
If having a rival is central to being an elite athlete so is this, leaving time to clear your head.
So it was we found ourselves following Shane Van Boning out on to pack Tola Lake in the Black Hills.
Van Boning goes fishing season be damned every morning when he's back home. We didn't catch any fish.
We did catch Van Boning's drift though. His take on the virtues of complete silence.
Vanity plate notwithstanding few extravagances come with being number one in pool.
The Ragtag Pro Tour barely televised in the US struggles to draw much interest or investment
outside of pool die hard. How many sponsors do you have? I have six sponsors.
Cues and tables and pool products. Yes. And any sponsors outside of pool? No. What can a top
player make? Top player and pool can make only a fish finish. After a spanishes maybe five
fish. No one's making a million bucks. No. That's a pool player. Never happened.
Van Boning says cleaning up the sport, doing away with backroom money games,
with lower big corporate sponsors, big media deals, and grow professional pool.
We saw first hand his discomfort with gambling and all that comes with it.
When we interviewed you in Derby City, I don't know if you remember the interview was interrupted.
Do you recall what happened? Oh, the gambling. Was that what happened? Yeah.
It was morning at Derby City and the action upstairs from the night before was still simmering.
Over the course of a few minutes two players who'd bet on a game nearly came to blow.
You cannot gamble. Van Boning could only shake his head. It got to be a clean sport.
Ender pro pools, unlikely new guardian, Emily Fraser of the British sports promoter Matru.
The company recently revamped pro darts and snooker in the UK,
streamlining their circuits and turning top players into celebrities who make millions.
That's where the trophy sits. Fraser is tasked with doing the same for pool,
and she says gambling is the least of her worries. What's the state of professional pool today?
Ah, an absolute mess. Why do you say that? The first ever US Open that I did in 2019.
Oh my gosh, the players turned up. They were in jeans. When I'm going,
hang on a second, what's happening here? Why is this guy turning up in jeans?
Fraser has asked pro players to dress the part, but you won't ask them to give up their side hustles.
Now, all of the basement tables and the money matches, I think that's brilliant.
And that can still... Yeah, I think that's fantastic because it's got the history behind it.
You're okay if people are still, they're gambling and playing money games.
As far as I'm concerned, in a couple years time, they won't need to have any money matches.
It'll be absolute. The market will do its thing.
Exactly, but right now, it's not viewed as this professional sport.
And it has all the ingredients to be one.
She standardized the format. This is commercialized sponsor-friendly
nine-ball, not the solids and stripes eight-ball you've likely played.
In October at the US Open, held in Atlantic City, Fraser brought in bigger live audiences
and ramped up TV production. She's kept one pool hallmark, the smoke-filled room.
Close, but no cigar. There's a machine puffing away in the corner.
When the smoke cleared, there was Shane Van Boney.
He was fresh off winning his first world championship,
sealing his status atop the sport.
He confided to us that he'd slept with the trophy for a month.
Van Boney is mobbed at pool tournaments, but can still walk through an airport unbothered.
Well, he's no LeBron James and I totally understand that and I recognize that.
It's our job to turn that around. It is our responsibility to turn
that world number one prize money from $80,000 to a million.
So it's prize money. It's more events and let's get these players known.
You've got to fall in love with them. Are they loveable?
Yes, some of them.
The health of the sport also depends on minting a new generation of elite players.
So this tournament had a junior division held alongside the pros and named
what else the Shane Van Boney junior opened.
These are future pros?
Oh, yeah, definitely. Definitely.
They have so much passion for the game.
And then I'm going to shoot the sish.
Back at the pool hall in Rapid City, we experience pools, highs and lows in the same hour.
You didn't even let me hit a ball.
Ever the sports gentleman, Shane Van Boney wouldn't let us leave without setting us up to
sink a trick shot. Pool, May or may not clean up its act.
But any sport that can provide this kind of pure, simple thrill.
Let's go right down the middle.
Yep, right down the middle.
You reckon it'll survive just fine.
You got that.